Saudi Arabia is unique in the whole
world in that a it has the largest
reserve of oil in the world which gives
us you can imagine enormous power and it
contains the holy places of Islam the
cities of Mecca and Medina that every
Muslim 1 and 1.8 billion Muslims are
supposed to visit those shrines in the
course of their lifetime these are on
either side of the Arabian continent and
in the middle you have riad and the
House of Saud the princely family which
controls both these sources of economic
power and religious power with their own
very puritanical interpretation of Islam
Saudi Arabia is the only country in the
world that is named after each ruling
family Saudi I when I first went there I
thought Saudi Arabia met southern Arabia
so it means Arabia as conquered ruled
pulled together by the House of Saud six
seven thousand princes and as many
princesses of course but we don't see so
much of them
coming into New York today to do this
thinking what a lovely beautiful autumn
day was I couldn't help thinking of the
accounts I dread of 911 and the tragedy
of 911 which was of course terrible
tragedy and we're still living with the
effects but in a weird way 911 was a
very good thing for Saudi Arabia because
15 of the 19 hijackers were Saudis the
mastermind of course Osama bin Laden was
and is a Saudi and although it took a
time for the Saudis to acknowledge this
they were responsible in many ways for
the hatred and bitterness and
intolerance and anger that produced 911
and they've been trying since then
certainly King Abdullah has been trying
to make amends mother make amends to
turn the country in a new direction like
for example taking the intolerance out
of textbooks in traditional Islam as a
great a great fear of non-muslims
infidels that turns into hatred I'm it's
a phenomenon we know in our own cultures
trying to get more dialogue between the
different faiths I remember going to
Madrid last year to see the King meet
rabbis religious shakes bishops
Christian pastors Buddhist monks to
create a spirit of religious dialogue
but he the king of Saudi Arabia could
never convened a meeting like that
inside Saudi Arabia there would be
revolt at the idea that he was bringing
these foreign religious figures to the
Holy Land and that was a big factor in
911 911 was really a Saudi quarrel
played out in Manhattan Osama bin Laden
wanted to attack what he called the near
enemy by which he meant the House of
Saud who he sees as as westernizing and
corrupting the old traditional holy land
and so he did that by attacking the far
enemy which is America
who has sustained Saudi Arabia by
developing its oil by buying its oil and
by with military methods or in
innumerable ways America has made Saudi
Arabia the power that it is in the world
the sound is one to take from us the
best of the west but not what they view
was the worst for example a month or so
ago in Saudi Arabia there was a radio
talk show host who started boasting as
radio talk show host tend to and he got
onto his sex life before he was married
and all the girls he'd seduced and
talked about how he he would pick them
up and get them into bed and there was
outrage now the government didn't do
anything but ordinary viewers phoned in
and a local lawyer prosecutor took the
guy to court he was sentenced to five
years in jail and five hundred lashes
for being profane on the radio and also
for insulting Islam because any sex
outside marriage not just during
marriage but before marriage for
traditional Muslims concerns you to hell
so he was admitting that he was a bad
Muslim now not many Saudis would
complain that that man's freedom of
expression was being infringed by
jailing him he'll do his five years
he'll get lashed 500 times that's the
sort of conservatism that exists they
you know they have beach resorts in
Saudi Arabia private beach resorts
behind high walls recently a number of
them feel that too many young girls are
wearing bikinis too many loud parties
too many fathers feel their daughters
are getting picked up by an unsuitable
men so they've invited the old religious
police in to keep order it's impossible
in Saudi Arabia for a young single man
to go into a shopping mall on his own
you're only allowed in if you're a young
male or indeed an old male with women
with your family because otherwise the
fear is quite rightly that you know
shopping malls away young people meet to
pick each other up young Saudi men will
complain about this but if you say to
them oh
see you so would you like you'd like the
right to go into a more without being
stalked by a security guard would you
like your sister to have the right to go
into shopping mall and meet strange men
oh no they say oh no no I my sister is
going to marry someone that my family
approve our mother I approve of so you
know it's only I mean 1938 was when oil
was discovered another 10 years before
the money really started to filter
through so I know what are we talking
about only 50 years has western style
life been in this country and the
reaction of it of people to it is still
very suspicious and still very
conservative
Saudi Arabia is living in the 1950s in
many way well actually it's living in
the 15th century in Islamic years Saudi
Arabia is now in the year 1430 and that
in well America didn't even exist then
as a Western white state and in Europe
we had the Inquisition we there was no
religious tolerance in 1430 in Europe
you belong to one particular religion
the Catholic religion and if you urge
from that you will get burned so when
people get upset about and I can
understand it public executions in the
street in Saudi Arabia beheadings i
meanit's I've seen in my time there
three I think you don't see them every
day and happily I've always arrived
afterwards but you know people get upset
about that although 70 80 of those a
year that's about the number of people
that get executed in death rows in
America people say well it shouldn't be
public well you know all all gas
chambers in America electric chair
chambers have viewing galleries and
people forget that when Timothy McVeigh
was executed in this 21st century the
American government rounded up 250
relatives so they could come and watch
the man being executed on television so
let's not get too superior about these
Saudis and you know one of the upsides
of this very fierce capital code and
moral code is that what I'm living there
which I still do I can go out in the
street any time of day or night to any
part of any Saudi city totally safely
there's no no go areas where you're
going to get mugged there are areas
where you might find drug dealers you
won't find red light districts in Saudi
Arabia I mean there may be prostitutes
somewhere but you know that's something
for example the Saudis don't want the
idea that in European city
well in American states that you would
have legalized prostitution that I think
you're never going to see in in Saudi
Arabia after all they are the Holy Land
and so they're aware that they are
judged by Muslims all over the world at
the moment for example like we're
talking now end of 2009 they're very
worried about the pilgrimage coming up
the swine flu they're going to the rest
incredible lengths to avoid any sort of
epidemic because a they don't want
pilgrims to to suffer from it but be
they don't want the Muslim world to say
you can't keep us healthy when we come
on pilgrimage
Saudi Arabia would be lost if an
alternative energy source to oil were
discovered in the near future that would
actually pull the carpet out from under
the the Saudi economy because Saudi
economy is based for the next 20 30
years on on the revenues from oil
they're trying to diversify also from
oil and gas you can make petrochemicals
and most people would think that even if
we find alternative sources of energy we
will still need plastics in the future
so Saudi Arabia is working very hard to
develop that but the the other thing
it's trying to do and this is what King
Abdullah is trying he's trying to create
a sort of Arab Silicon Valley around the
scientific research establishments that
have started to be set up at his new
University for example there are not
just laboratories for research every
single research discovery then goes to a
business workshop I mean this is an
American model and there are economists
and business businessmen there who right
from the moment of the first inkling of
some new technology or discovery are
working out how to bring in capital and
turn that into enterprise because jobs
will have to be the salvation of Saudi
Arabia in the future and internet it's a
big question mark